Oh
scarves been out for you know I think
about six months it may be almost a year
now came out last winter yeah so you
know why Skyrim and why right now the
right now is a really interesting
question um so the reason that I chose
Skyrim and I tell everybody this because
the moment you know you put together a
piece of work as a filmmaker people are
like oh that's what that person does
meaning I put together a game parody and
a lot of people are like oh she's gamer
girl it's like well I'm a geek and I do
my genre choice is actually
action/comedy action comedy fantasy more
along the lines of action fantasy like
I'm I totally did drama I do comedy and
so I'm not a huge gamer but last year
around like November came out you know I
was I wasn't working a lot at the time
like the holidays are very slow period
in Los Angeles you know especially
filmmaking a television and I was kind
of bored and so my friends were like you
have to try this this new David came out
with seriously the best game on earth
called Skyrim and so I went out and
bought it and I completely became
obsessed with it and I played it for
like a hundred hours so like 80 to 100
hours and I started like constantly
talking about it and tight i was like i
could be like sword fighting and I you
know I'm like an ace at Magic because
that's like my thing and around the
holidays in december it was like I just
started thinking about Lydia who's my
companion and like my boyfriend always
come in while I'm playing and you know
he laughed because I'm yelling at her
and I'm swearing at her and I'm calling
her names and I was like you know what I
kind of want to do like a parody of
Lydia because she's so stupid like I
love her but she was a stupid I don't
know if you play the game I did yeah
aggressively yeah but but as filmmakers
and the storytellers we look at
everything as a story we you know it's
like what's the experience here so
that's that's how I came about to do to
Lydia with love as I was like I just
want to do parody and I did it in my
living room on a green screen you know I
had people come help me out
I'm a costume designer so I thought of
it as a great opportunity to wear make
my own costume so they're all replicas
of the game and then you know i have
like swords at home and I was like oh
this is great this is totally up my
alley you know it's fantasy its action
it's funny this is exactly what I want
to do so I think this would be a fun
project for me and so I launched that in
about like early februari and it just
blew up so that was only one video and
everybody was watching it everybody was
talking about it and so I thought it
would be kind of fun to do another
series of like some of them have to do
with Lydia some of them have to do with
just Skyrim in general but the reason
why I wanted to continue with that I
mean that's kind of why I did Skyrim in
the first place because it wasn't my
genre of choice and I did think it was a
really funny situation that I wanted to
share with everybody it's basically my
own experience in the game but I decided
to do a series because it's like okay
well now that I have all these fans and
I got all these subscribers and I have
all these people that are watching I'm
not only targeting the people that had
played the game because they're they're
obviously you know there's gamers that
get a game and they play it for a month
and then they're like I'm done with that
game but there is still to this day a
lot of people that don't know what
Skyrim is I'm kind of encouraging them
to you know I'm like epithets the
salesperson I'm encouraging them to have
played the game and so the reason why it
is almost a year is because we had our
IndieGoGo I had an IndieGoGo campaign in
May and then that ran for a month and
and I got like fifty five hundred
dollars from people who are awesome too
fun six more parodies but because i'm
still like considered like a low-budget
production you know I do a lot of things
myself I work during the day it's just
taken a really long time to actually
shoot create all the costumes get all
the stuff together and then the majority
of the time is actually spent in
post-production because we shoot
everything on green-screen and then we
have to go in and kind of create the
world's after the fact so so what I did
was I said okay the skyrim parodies are
going to launch november 11
and I saw well rather than just doing it
like randomly in the middle of the
summer or randomly in the fall why don't
we just hold off until the one-year
anniversary of the game and sort of make
it an ode to Skyrim and so that's
planning on doing a math why it's kind
of looped around to a full year when the
game came out because it did take the
time for me to actually play then decide
that I wanted to cover it then do the
IndieGoGo and all that fun stuff which
anybody that works in filmmaking knows
it takes a while to do everything so
that's what my really long would the
gist of why Skyrim and why now cool um
you know you've mentioned at your
costume designer and you know that's
traditionally not a digital profession
how has youtube and digital video helped
you kind of increase your career as a
costume designer well it wouldn't
necessarily say that I'm not a bona fide
I work for big-budget films costume
designer but what it does for me you
know i love cosplay I've been doing it
since I don't know when since I was
younger you know I love dressing up and
making costumes and all that fun stuff
and so what I think I'll say what it's
helped me in a sense that I don't
actually have to hire anybody else to
create the vision of my piece and
because I'm really into sci-fi and
fantasy that's just such a great genre
that opens itself up to really cool
costumes and so the webseries world I
mean in a sense it's a it's a little bit
more probably a lot more low budget than
a lot of the major film studios and so
in putting my stuff online you know
first of all like I said it helps me
save money because I can do that stuff
myself and I also know that it's going
to be quality and like for Skyrim for
example you know I made videos whole
garb out of like fake armor and plastic
and I know that I can make it look as
good as I want it to do to by doing it
myself but the web like doing it in a
series form and doing it in short videos
and having so many people look at it you
know that enables them to see that I'm
not just a filmmaker or an
dress but I do a number of different
things you know I'm actually I have a
background of design I do a lot of
graphic design and use your experience
and costumes you know props all of that
fun stuff and so I think it kind of just
lets everybody know that I'm this
multi-faceted person that does a lot of
fun creative things I of course hi my
name's in the credits like 800 times it
has to be so you had mentioned that you
know web series are traditionally known
as being low budget um do you think it's
harder for Hollywood and major you know
studios and networks to take webseries
seriously because they are traditionally
what low budget um when I say low budget
I don't mean low production quality by
any means I mean that we don't usually
usually web series because um well what
web series are really great in that
creator could put their own stuff
together in their own voice and they can
have a directly go to web so that's what
I love about it is there's no filtering
process through Hollywood where you know
I don't know like if any for anybody
that's not familiar with the process in
Hollywood it could take years to get
even a script through you know you're
writing a script it takes years to maybe
possibly get something even interested
in it and then once they shoot it a
production company takes it over they
fund it they get a director they
completely do whatever they want with it
so by the time your creation gets on
screen if it ever gets on screen and
there's very few percentage that do it's
a lot of times like it's gone through
this whole process of involving a bunch
of other people and it might not be your
voice in the end so what web series does
is it gives directors of chance and
producers and creators and writers a
chance to sort of create their own work
and get it directly out to fans and so
in that sense I think in the very
beginning like maybe a few years ago
Hollywood thought the web you know come
on it's just a bunch of people like they
don't have a lot of money they're just
throwing their stuff out there but I
think today it's changed dramatically I
think that Hollywood is now hiring
people on the web because they're still
in this old school way of thinking and
there and they're trained to only think
of this huge complicated process
and then they're looking at people
online going oh my god that guy has like
oh like a million subscribers we could
utilize him and his fans and his like
obviously he's doing something right you
know we can utilize his talents for us
and we can hire him to help us sort of
push our product so nowadays I think
Hollywood is actually in turn hiring a
lot of people on line one for their fans
like let's be honest they are all about
finding ways to save time and money and
so they're going to pick people that are
more established but you they see that
these people are tech savvy and web
savvy and they have a voice and so
they're hiring them for like those
specific talents and the web allows you
to get those talents seen much bigger
than going through the old-school way I
don't I don't think Hollywood is I think
how I was afraid of the people in the
webseries world actually Oh vendors but
do you think that maybe you know because
Hollywood is recruiting a lot of people
from web series it could put you know
the webseries industry in danger of
people just using it kind of as a
springboard to get to Hollywood versus
you know actually staying in the web and
you know increasing that culture in that
community making it better while
everyone instead goes to hollywood i
think in the very beginning and i have
to be honest i thought this way myself I
thought for the longest time because you
know web series is so new I want it I
wanted to work in television I I wanted
to work in the series world in episodic
and so I thought will TV that's the best
way that people are going to see me well
I actually had to educate myself on the
fact that no it's really not in fact
today you know being a younger person
people aren't you know people don't have
cable they can't afford cable or they
don't even know where to find you know
content on you know on cable or online
you know some of the major networks
because it's so time consuming to sit
down and research a show and then you
have to wait every week to see the show
and you have you know blah blah blah
blah so I think nowadays people are
actually watching more content online
now grant it they have a much shorter
attention span but they are
a lot of content online and so I think
that we're evolving the web series world
to be just as huge as I'll say
television film is still film you know
you're always going to go the movies and
you're going to watch film but in terms
of like especially episodic or maybe the
shorter series short films and that sort
of thing I think or parodies skips I
think that online is is really growing
and I think that this industry is
getting so big now that people are
they're actually more open to new
technology they're integrating social
media more they're having more fun with
it and I think it's just going to be
another big application for a creator so
the in my mind they'll be film they'll
be television and they'll be web series
and I think they're all going to be
equally as big you know whether or not
macadam e awards recognizes that I don't
know but they still don't think TV is
serious sometimes right see that's the
funny thing in Hollywood that filmmakers
were soaked like like as an actor if you
were Angelina Jolie it was it was def
your career to do anything on television
for the longest time because they were
like oh wow that's just that's just
secondary to film and now look at TV all
the big stars are like HBO yeah I want
to be on Dexter I want to be a guest
star on the show because it's just as
big so i think the web world is going to
be what TV was a few years ago and it's
going to be like you're going to start
seeing Tom Cruise online all the time
that's what he's gonna do he's gonna
take well cool i guess my last question
real quick just just throwing it out
there you know um if you had to choose
between to live in two different worlds
okay fantasy world with dragons and
knights and all that stuff and sci-fi
world with aliens and robots and rocket
ships which one you picking kind of
fantasy girl i love i love robots but I
I grew up with movies like The Dark
Crystal and labyrinth and I'm I'm so
about like elaborate costumes and
stories I left swords I mean I love a
laser gun or lightsaber any day but I'm
all about swords so I'm a huge fantasy
fan
that's my genre of choice no I'm not um
I'm open to doing sci-fi but i think my
love and I'll of spaceships but I think
my love is definitely the fantasy world
and Dragons come on an awesome well cool
thanks so much for taking the time to
talk to me I really appreciate it yeah
yeah okay so where can people check out
your work we can find all of my stuff on
my website Kristin netip a calm and easy
Oh PA k or i'm on twitter at meadow pack
any GOP AK and i have a bunch of shows
up right now so the skyrim parodies is
skyrim parodies calm and then on my
website you can check out my other show
called fight class where we actually
break down the behind-the-scenes
choreography for movies and I and I work
with sword masters and we learn
everything and then we just put it on
camera so we kind of show you how it's
done so yeah but you can usually find
everything on my website awesome cool
thank you
Oh